Good morning, Hank, as you can tell by the grey speckled walls behind me, I'm in an airport.
It's Question Tuesday, the day that I answer real questions
from real Nerdfighters. Today I'm going to answer questions about
love, and sex.
When do you think it's okay to lose your virginity?
You know, call me old fashioned, but I don't think 34 year old men vlogging in airports should
decide when other people have sex.
I like this guy and I think he likes me back, but I'm not sure. How do I find out for sure?
I'm gonna tell you what I tell Henry several times a day:
"Use your words!"
Just talk to him - if you start going out you're going to have to talk to him anyways.
There's a girl in my school who I like but I don't exactly know-
JUST ASK HER using your words! You're not an Avox!
Wait - or are you? If you're an Avox, write it down.
What is your stand on birth control pills?
I try not to stand on birth control pills at all; I think it might decrease their effectiveness.
How do you say no to sex without offending your partner?
To answer your question, lets make a Venn Diagram.
Let this circle be asshats
and here are the people who get offended when you say no to sex.
Do you think it matters how many people someone has slept with?
No, and it particularly bothers me that women are held to a different standard on this front than men.
Also, it's such a weird thing to care about. Like, imagine if I started eating cheerios for breakfast
would cheerios be like "I'm the 48th cereal you've tried eating, I don't feel special!"
Well, then screw you cheerios I can't go into the past and un-eat all those cereals but that doesn't mean
I don't genuinely enjoy your whole grain crunch.
How do I know he's the "one"?
I don't think there is one "one". Have you ever had a crush on a band member?
Let me ask your question with a question: is Toby Turner in a band?
John, do you ship wholock?
Sometimes I feel like you guys just make up words to confuse me.
When is it too soon to say "I love you?"
Just remember you can't un-ring that bell.
Have you ever wanted to experience giving birth?
No, I've seen birth.
No. Yeah, no. No, no, no...no.
Is there a way to tell if he actually cares or if he just
wants a hookup?
Yeah is he a douchebag?
The first time you saw the Yeti, did you think she was the one?
No, the first time I saw the Yeti she was in 8th grade
and I did not think, 'Oh I'm gonna marry that 8th grader!'
What do you think of an "Othello" kind of love?
You mean the kind where you beat up the love of your life and then kill her?
I'm opposed to it.
In your opinion, is pre-marital sex wrong?
I certainly don't think there's anything inherently wrong with pre-marital sex.
Like for example, it's legal for gay people to be married in some states
but not in others and it's a little bit ridiculous to say that it's possible
for gay people to have morally justifiable sex in Vermont
but not in Mississippi.
Frankly, I don't really see it as my job to tell people
who they should have sex with or under what circumstances.
Also this is an awkward thing to talk about in an airport.
*sings* The people in the airport think that I'm crazy.
The people in the airport think that I'm crazy.
And maybe I am to be fair.
What is the secret to a successful marriage?
Mutual generosity, also it's nice that you can like the same television programs.
Is it wrong to do gay stuff, like just kissing?
Aw man, your question makes me so sad.
No, of course it's not wrong. If you wanna kiss someone
and that person wants to kiss you back that is awesome.
And don't let anyone tell you you should be ashamed about that.
People are so ashamed about their sexuality but you shouldn't be.
It's great!
I'm talking about it in Terminal A of the  Indianapolis airport.
On average, what animal takes the longest to copulate?
I don't know, but I do know that llama sex lasts like two hours
because male llamas experience something called "dribble ejaculation".
How do I know these things?
He loves me and I don't love him and he won't take
no for an answer?
Yeah, then he doesn't love you.
He doesn't even respect your right to choose your own romantic partners.
Is it weird that I'm in college and I've never kissed anyone?
Not at all, as evidenced by the fact that your question was the most
thumbed up out of the hundreds I got on Facebook.
How do you cover up a hickey?
Hickies are still a thing? I never understood hickies.
It's like, "I like you, so I'm gonna suck on your neck until there's bruising."
How can I ask someone if he's gay in a subtle way?
*in pig latin* Are you gay?
Just ask them! Use your words!
Nerdfighters, thanks for the great questions.
Hank, I have to go get on a plane. I will see you on Friday!